okay so again we understand our purpose
we know ourselves what is our main goal
in this world and we constantly check in
inside inside this is very important
inner management in there engineering we
always see outside do outside but check
inside check in with your brain your
heart your gut how do you feel about
what you're doing and check in with
yourself more often about your purpose
your destiny and then you see how it can
be applicable to something like the
United Nations sustainable development
goals the biggest challenges on the
planet
how can your science become
translationally applicable to the
biggest challenges on the planet make a
list of your top 5 your top 10 your top
50 people that you want to get in touch
with in the field and do research about
what they're doing at the edge of their
field synthesize ask questions work on
our social skills build groups of people
that we can engage with on these
cutting-edge topics and share that
content around China in the world know
someone's opinion may contradict yours
what is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao shechet shreddin shechet you long
e pecking university i will not be
speaking in Mandarin I wish I could my
name is Alan Saki on I host a show
called simulation in San Francisco
California where we interview some of
the greatest minds across all different
fields biotech neuro tech AI and
robotics blockchain and cryptocurrency
emotional intelligence geopolitics
meditation and spirituality we feature
all different leaders from different
fields and we'll be talking about some
of the strategies that we can embody to
help us reach our maximum potential
fastest one of the most important pieces
of advice over the last thousands of
years that people have been talking
about ever since the beginning of
civilization is know thyself so who are
you what is your purpose what is your
mission what are your goals what are
your dreams what are your aspirations
you know here we are in the Life
Sciences Building at picking University
so many of you are focused on biology
animals plants neuroscience all
different aspects of the life sciences
is this what is gonna get you excited
every single morning when you wake up
and you say I'm very excited to go and
pursue my field of research so that's
the big question is look at look at
ourselves in the mirror and figure out
everyday is this what I'm doing that I'm
most passionate about that I'm most
excited to wake up in the morning and do
every single day
it's that first piece of advice know
yourself and if you don't know exactly
what you want to do in life sciences or
if you don't know exactly what how you
want to apply it out into the world a
really great place to start is by
looking at something like the
sustainable development goals so you can
identify how your life sciences can help
with ending poverty with maximizing
education with helping our environment
around the world with helping feed
everyone around the planet there's so
many different ways to increase our
longevity and so this is another really
good way to kind of be able to see what
exactly how we'll do how do I want my
science to make a translational impact
out into the real world so much of what
we want to achieve is based on people
that we connect with that we network
with that we meet and so we have this
idea called a top 50 that we like
sharing so how many of you and you can
raise your hand how many of you have a
list of at least five people that you
want to get in touch with that you would
like to maybe mentor you where you'd
like to get coffee with how many raise
your hand if you have a list of five
people one two three four five six okay
so this is very good this is very good
that you have these lists because this
is one of the most simple things to do
to maximize your potential if you have
at least the list at least you know in
the general direction more for where you
want to go and what you want to achieve
so if you want to study something like
neuroscience and you want to get deeper
into neuroscience who are five leaders
in neuroscience that are doing things
that you find really interesting
and then learn more about them learn
more about them and learn more about
their research and why is that important
well what people are doing is they're
usually pushing what is called the edge
of knowledge it's the farthest out we
know we know the brain is very
complicated and so some people are doing
some things with the brain that are at
the edge of what humans know about brain
science and so if you want to go and
find people at the edge you can more
easily find them as mentors you can more
easily advance your career and advance
your impact that way so if there's at
least one thing to take away from this
talk is make your list of the people
that you want that you look up to that
you want to get in touch with that you
want to do more research about you see
how it sets a goal and then it gives us
something to reach out towards yes and
when you do identify those people you
start doing research on them and there's
a lot of different ways to do research
on people this is one way that I
personally really enjoy which is going
and finding we have an interview with
you long later today and you are all
welcome to sit int in that interview if
you would like the whole audience the
whole and so what have I been doing I
already have a note in my notes with you
Long's name on it and it has information
about him I've been looking up his lap
I've been looking up his papers I've
been looking up what he studies and I've
been adding that information into my
notes so I'm parsing what he's been
doing finding the key points putting
them into my notes and then synthesizing
adding my own ideas my own questions my
own ways of thinking
to what he's been studying and so by
doing this research you can do this via
videos you can do this via papers you
can do this via via journal articles all
different types of ways audio podcasts
and so by doing this you gain a better
understanding of these you know five
people that you want to reach out to in
plant science and if you want to reach
out to them you do research on them you
get to know what they're doing better
and then you can more easily do
something like organize you and your
friends to come together and get talking
about what's going on at that edge of
science so in order for us to become
really well-rounded people we have to
learn social skills we have to learn
emotional intelligence we have to learn
empathy we have to learn how to look at
someone in the eyes and have that deep
genuine love and curiosity for who they
are and what they strive to achieve in
their life these social skills will take
all of your science and amplify it 5-10
times because you will become better and
better at talking to other people at
collaborating with other people at
networking with other people this social
skills makes sense it's very important
yes okay because it'll help the science
so much other aspects of the social
skills are like emotion regulation so if
something comes up and you're starting
to feel a little neurotic about it lots
of emotions flying everywhere
you know you this is emotion regulation
maybe go out and go for a walk go out
into nature for a little bit or maybe
do something like go exercise no how can
you regulate your emotions so that we're
not dwelling on negative thoughts but
that we're constantly going towards a
more and more positive future for
yourselves and for us all perseverance
is also crucial how many times do we hit
a wall we hit walls all the time in
everything we do and so to be able to go
past that wall of adversity it's like a
test of faith every one of those walls
is like a test all my experiment failed
yeah that's gonna happen we're gonna
have we're gonna have challenges like
this come up and we have to persevere
through them and we have to have good
friends and family and community that
helps us get through these things so
these social skills are so crucial to
advance the science as well
and then once you do get a couple
friends that are really interested in
that field of animal science or in that
field cell biology maybe if you're
studying the mitochondria what you want
to do is you want to find five other
people that are also interested in the
mitochondria and its effects in a cell
in the body and then what you do is you
set up a group you set up a group that
can specifically go and study the most
cutting-edge research on mitochondrial
science and then you can all talk
together you all go do research and you
come back and you share ideas about what
you think is happening at the edge of
the science and how you can ask
questions that maybe haven't been asked
before and then what you do with the
content maybe you spend an hour or two
hours taking a bunch of notes asking a
bunch of questions maybe you want to do
something like like take a picture of
what your biggest questions were and
maybe you want to take a picture of the
group and how you guys got together and
maybe you want to post that into WeChat
and you want to start sharing that
publicly so more people around China and
around the world can get interested in
what you're studying and it's like a
butterfly effect that happens someone
sees you talking about some cutting-edge
science and they say wow I didn't know
that that was happening I want to get
more involved too and we have a more
knowledgeable world so the sharing side
of this is really crucial as well okay
so again we understand our purpose we
know ourselves what is our main goal in
this world and we constantly check in
inside inside this is very important in
our management in their engineering we
always see outside do outside but check
inside check in with your brain your
heart your gut how do you feel about
what you're doing and check in with
yourself
more often about your purpose your
destiny and then you see how it can be
applicable to something like the United
Nations sustainable development goals
the biggest challenges on the planet how
can your science become translationally
applicable to the biggest challenges on
the planet make a list of your top 5
your top 10 your top 50 people that you
want to get in touch with in the field
and do research about what they're doing
at the edge of their field synthesize
ask questions work on our social skills
build groups of people that we can
engage with on these cutting-edge topics
and share that content around China in
the world so that's it that's it for the
this portion of the talk I wanted to
keep it very short I wanted to open it
up for a lots of questions from the
audience I want to you know go back and
forth with you guys about you what your
questions may be and maybe I can help
provide some some insight you know I was
actually talking to shorten yesterday
about about some of the differences
between the United States and China
because in so many ways you know we're
human and and we and we have families
and friends and love and all these types
of things very similar things but
there's like different cultural dynamics
in a sense where in the United States I
may be comfortable doing something like
sending a cold email out to someone
that's you know in that list of my maybe
top 10 top 50 people but maybe in China
it's not so okay to do something like
send out just a cold email so there's
these interesting different cultural
dynamics that I'd love to you know to
unpack and just see maybe there are some
things that we can talk about that I can
share I can learn from you you guys can
learn from maybe what I have to share so
that's it sure sure thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]